pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en effet sur ces images prises
pour la première fois parmi les hommes
d'une compagnie opérationnel à l'algérie
que nous avons tenu à ouvrir ce premier
numéro de cinq colonnes à la une
l'algérie où vivent et se battent des
milliers et des milliers de jeunes gens
de france les appeler nous allons vous
faire vivre ce soir la vie de l'un d'eux
le sergent charlie robert première
section troisième compagnie 15e
bataillon de tirailleurs algériens
l'histoire du sergent robert elle
s'inscrit entre ce piton rocheux en
algérie sa vie d'aujourd'hui et ce
village de provence où habitent ses
parents sa vie y est quand le sergent
robert pense à la france et à ce village
cette maison qu'il pense sa maison il
son village natal il pense à ce visage
qui est celui de sa mère à cet instant
qui presque à la même heure dans tous
les villages de france et le meilleur de
la journée l'instant du facteur
[Musique]
ils pensent aussi sans doute à ce
remue-ménage bruyant qui est celui d'une
maisonnée de onze enfants
le 12e n'est pas là car le douzième
c'est lui le sergent robert
il pense à cette table et de midi où
l'on commentait il n'ya guère longtemps
en riant ses exploits d'adolescents et
où aujourd'hui en lice et lettres à
haute voix leurs sacrés du repas dans un
silence recueilli
alors ce soir à l'occasion du nouvel an
cinq colonnes à la une a voulu offrir un
cadeau à la famille robert et à travers
elle à toutes les familles de france
dont les êtres chers se battent en
algérie grâce à nos envoyés spéciaux
andré hude et roland hulot grâce à la
télévision qui abolit les distances
grâce à notre collaborateur roland
dhordain qui se trouve en ce moment en
provence auprès d'eux devant le petit
écran
nous allons faire vivre pendant quelques
instants à son père à sa mère à ses
frères et assesseurs la vie du soldat
robert de la première section 3e
compagnie du 15e bataillon de
tirailleurs algériens alors dordain
sommes nous prêts
le cercle de famille est un peu restera
ce soir mais il y a beaucoup d'émotions
ici
vous devinez pourquoi madame robert
merci de nous avoir reçus je ne présente
pas non plus monsieur robert nous
l'avons vu
mademoiselle annie vous êtes quel numéro
de la famille pour qui représentait les
enfants ce soir ce numéro combien le 8e
et bien vous allez donc voir grâce aux
envoyés spéciaux de cinq colonnes à la
une le document tourné il y à quelques
vingt cas de 48 heures en algérie
alors si vous êtes préparés à vous eh
bien madame robert monsieur robert à
partir de cet instant c'est à vous que
nous allons nous adresser
regardez bien ces vues elles ont été
prises avec votre fils il n'ya pas 48
heures en algérie
et j'ai en ce moment à côté de moi le
lieutenant philippe et dui qui
appartient au même bataillon que votre
fils et qui est arrivé la nuit dernière
tout exprès de sétif pour faire vivre à
votre intention ces images que vous
n'avez sans doute jamais vu et auquel
pourtant vous avez dû si souvent songé
alors lieutenant et lui où sommes nous
bien nous sommes sur la piste l'unique
piste qui conduit au poste où vit
actuellement le sergent robert ou plus
généralement nous sommes ou qu'ils aient
des mondiaux non massif du adna qui se
trouve entre les aurès et la kabylie et
qui est un des derniers refuges de la
réunion je crois d'ailleurs que dans
quelques secondes on va apercevoir des
guetteurs sur une crête et parmi eux
secondes
ce jour là se trouvait ce jour là le
sergent robert
comme chaque fois chaque jour le convoi
qui n'ont compost est protégé voilà le
voilà charlie charlie qui est chef de
groupe de combat et voici son groupe de
combat ils se tiennent sur la crête
environ- 12 100 mètres d'altitude
bonjour c'est notre boulot de 22 ans le
rappeler oui appelé quinze jours
seulement
qu'est ce que vous faites dans six
villes pâtissier avait géré vos voire un
an
et vous qui arrive à tous et votre
métier mécanicien à voilà le chef de
section serge ben oui commune avec
service deux ans ça s'est arrêté
ailleurs rails et vous tirez la forte
offert à vous êtes alsaciens ont franchi
le rhin le haut rhin et quel métier 6
heures
et copain à côté ainsi parisien du 9e
arrondissement
bravo regardez même adapté c'est malsain
jean-robert troisième compagnie
tirailleurs algériens
ah bah ça tombe bien justement voulez
vous voir en ce moment votre père votre
mairie
regardez alors si vous avez quelque
chose à leur dire profitez-en
je peux leur dire que je les embrasse
bien fort et au plaisir de les revoir
bientôt parce que naturellement je sais
de la classe en guise de il faut que
j'avais prévenir le poste que vous
arrivez
pimentez noirs ici piémont ténor mobile
je vous signale l'arrivée du convoi reçu
par les voiliers philippe et dui que en
ce moment la famille robert regarde ces
images nous allons donc essayer de faire
vivre une journée du sergent robert à
son père et à sa mère et nous allons
commencer par l'endroit où il se
réveille chaque matin qui est qui et le
post un poste tout nouvellement
construit qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
entièrement achevées ce poste se
trouvera au centre d'une région
complètement dénudée comme il est il
donne dans sport une centaine une
centaine
divisés comme ceux ci 50 % environ de
français de souche et 50% de français
musulmans qui est de l'effectif d'une
compagnie et au delà des murs de ce
poste de le djebel vous apercevez le
djebel et dans ceux djebel les fellaghas
est ce qu on les aperçoit par exemple
est-ce que ce capteur est ce que le
sergent rob hillary elle arrive que l'on
aperçoive quelques cutter là exactement
sommet est arrivée dans ce village vous
ne vous demandez peut-être pas bien
compte mais c'est mechta ces maisons
sont à quelques 1 50 mètres environ du
poste et le poste protège voilà robert
où va-t-il
robert est accompagné d'un jeune appelé
comme lui qui le taleb de taleb du
dossier l'infirmier de la compagnie de
taleb et le maître d'école
alors aujourd'hui le plus chaud
[Musique]
vous ne vous rendez peut-être pas bien
compte mais une scène comme celle ci
était absolument impensable il ya deux
ans et c'est parce que pendant plusieurs
mois charlie et le talent est se sont
promenés dans ces mechta vous pouvez
voir si mal
mais pas tous
[Musique]
maintenant tu viens à l'école a dit pas
du tout je vous interromps vous êtes
instituteurs non vous êtes médecin alors
je vous vois soigner non est ce que vous
faites dans le civil
je suis plâtrier à villenauxe-la-grande
dans l'ombre c'est un appelé oui à quel
âge avez-vous 22 ans et vous venez de
parler d'école aussi vous avez beaucoup
d'élèves
oui j'en ai 80 vous allez maintenant oui
on va voir ça alors on vous suit madame
reverser le meilleur copain de votre
fils ce que le talent m n'a pas dit
c'est que il y a deux ans deux ans à
peine
yves hepp à 80,81 gosses à l'école y
avait à peine un ou deux et que ces
promenades patiente au coeur mais chaque
vie promenade que le talent est de féric
charlie que peu à peu les 80 des
souvenirs l'école est provisoirement
installé dans l'ancien poste
on va faire un petit exercice de lecture
on va prendre une phrase de la leçon
d'hier
vous allez répété moi à l'école une
nouvelle école va être construite en
éléments préfabriqués
une nouvelle école et un nouveau village
à cet endroit là et c'est l'armée
c'est une sergent robert et tous ses
camarades qui vont construire une
nouveau village avec les habitants ici
sont très pauvres quelques moutons
quelques moutons quelques bourricot une
terre une caillasse se demande comment
est-ce que le sergent robert a une
fonction dans cette école
oui il est le professeur de gymnastique
les professeurs de genève tous les jours
ils jouent comme ça avec les enfants oui
il aime beaucoup et qu'il appelle
sergent ou même certains le plus grand
l'appel charlie dans la cour de
récréation se trouve à l'intérieur des
barbelés de lancement font toujours le
dessus mais là on revient sur un an plus
tôt
[Musique]
maintenant je crois que ce garçon
qu'elle sait toujours ce coiffure qui
ressemble un peu à yves montand une
curieuse histoire voulez vous la
raconter à madame bel et bien
aujourd'hui c'est assez ville mais hier
c'était un militaire c'était un jeune
appelé qui a lu dans les journaux une
petite annonce
comme quoi on demandait un ancien
militaire et firent la classe à cet
endroit là et il restait il est resté il
était instituteur dans le civil et voici
maintenant deux nouveaux instituteurs et
dans ce dernier vous avez vu l'aspect
pacificateur du sergent robert et ses
camarades il n'y a pas hélas que cet
aspect là vous allez maintenant vivre
l'aspect du combattant dans la salle de
radio du post
le radio est en train de recevoir un
message en langage codé
un message qui appelle la compagnie en
opération et la compagnie va fournir une
section au bataillon
la section désigné sera celle du sergent
robert que voici qui marche en tête de
son groupe de combat et de derrière lui
vous apercevez son radio pour une
opération comme celle-ci à l'échelon au
bataillon
tous les moyens seront mis en oeuvre
mais l'artillerie même l'artillerie
lourde
lourdes l'aviation n'oublions pas que
ces images ont été prises en algérie il
y a moins de 48 heures par nos envoyés
spéciaux
mona robert robert nous sommes ici en
zone interdite en zone interdite green
zone où l'artillerie et l'aviation ont
peuvent tirer à n'importe quel moment
dans la zone ont été évacuées de tous
les habitants combien dure une opération
de ce genre d'opération de gens peut
durer quelques heures ou quelques jours
aller jusqu'à 15 jours
celle-ci s'achèvera avec la nuit
résultat vous allez peut-être comment
des résultats comme il arrive souvent le
résultat a l'air sera peut-être décevant
car une trouve en oublie celle là nous
n'avons rien trouvé
les fellaghas y entend porter morts et
blessés il ne croyait pas que chaque
jour chaque fois que nous sortons
l'opération nous nous accrochons comme
ça généralement le rebelle lui décroche
[Musique]
darty driller la dimension l'aviation
piste raf
dérobert je crois qu'on aperçoit ici
c'est pourquoi c'est son groupe de
combat pour aller vers la crète qu'ils
se trouvent pour imagine que de tels
moyens mis en oeuvre présente une
sécurité certaines pour les autres et
oui vous avez seulement en face dans ce
cas elle se nomme réseau d'une quinzaine
de rebelles tout au plus dans la nuit
est tombée
la section rentrant d'opérations aussi
robert avec tous ses camarades il porte
le chapeau de brousse comme armement
pistolets mitrailleurs ou fusils et ils
vont rentrer dans leur chambre et quelle
heure est il à peu près 8 à peu près 9
heures du soir ils ont déjeuné dîner sur
le terrain robert se présentent au
commandant de compagnie lui demande
comment s'est passée l'opération c'était
avant-hier les tirailleurs remettre
leurs pistolets mitrailleurs râteliers
nos ateliers
et voici robert qui entrent dans la coup
de sécurité à son pistolet mitrailleur
il trouve une lettre sur son lit eh bien
ce sont les dernières heures de la
journée du sergent robert et elles sont
les mêmes pour tous les gars de toutes
les compagnies
c'est l'heure la plus agréable celle où
on se laisse tomber sur son lit fatigué
et où l'on trouve le courrier de la
journée peut-être est-ce une lettre de
vous madame robert qui attendaient ce
soir là votre fils que lui disiez vous
eh bien vous avez entendu la question de
pierre desgraupes un euro vers que lui
écriviez joue à charlie fois raconter ce
qui se passait dans la famille oui les
nouvelles de tout le monde
famille monsieur robert je vous ai vu
sourire vous ai vu écrasé une larme
comme maintenant vous ai vu à prouver
est ce que vous saviez qu'il était aussi
professeur de gymnastique charlie non
vous n'aviez pas découvert sa volonté
non c'est une vocation tas d'exercices
et découvrir là bas avec beaucoup
d'autres et vous mademoiselle vous
l'avez reconnu
il était bien son grand chapeau écoutez
je comprends monsieur c'est un garçon
très slims et d'ailleurs oui dans la
population de chez lui oui et alors je
vois que ça s'en rapporte à son actif
dans l'action ce qu'il était parmi vous
dans votre famille et bien il l'est
resté là bas c'est à dire un chic
garçons comme il y en a tant en algérie
bien ne l'ont pas prolonger cette minute
d'émotion que vous comprendrez tout et
tout ce qui est nous regarder et nous
allons remercier madame robert monsieur
robert et mademoiselle annie de nous
avoir reçu ce soir ici pour les caméras
de cinq colonnes à la une
avoue paris
c'est le grand reporter cinéaste georges
deschênes bac qui nous a fait parvenir
ces images en cinémascope pour que nous
puissions vous montrer l'un de ces
concours de hula-hoop qui par milliers
ont égayé les américains cette année
george ryan backes a lui même
personnellement organisé en californie
avec l'aide d'un journal local un
concours de hula-hoop pour jumeaux et on
est venu militants autres exercices
collectifs au japon cette année on a
pris ainsi à se laver les dents à 60
mille écoliers
au début c'est difficile mais une fois
qu'on sait c'est pour la vie à
l'institut médical de moscou de
professeur vladimir renny quow a réussi
la grève d'une tête vivante sur un
animal vivant c'est la circulation
artérielles et veineuses du chien qui
alimente la tête parasites
cette greffe à peine croyable a été
réussi deux fois les deux têtes garde
chacune leur réaction on ose à peine
imaginer ce que ces expériences pourront
apporter à l'humanité
[Musique]
voilà
à miami qu'il y a un an avant de prendre
le départ adios éleva avait déclaré ce
sera ma dernière course si vous avez vu
ce document vous n'avez pu l'oublier ce
rire n d'amsterdam apprend à ses enfants
sourds muets à percevoir les sons sens
les entend elle leur apprend à percevoir
les sons en substituant à louise le sens
du toucher et le miracle se produit sans
entendre les enfants dansent en mesure
ce rire nl danses de joie
c'est peut-être le document le plus
émouvant de l'année
[Musique]
g
il
[Musique]
ce petit port où nos envoyés spéciaux
sont arrivés au lever du jour c'est le
port d'etel la ville où les
conversations s'arrête lorsqu'on
prononce tout vos le nom d'alain bombard
vous savez pourquoi
c'est parce qu'un matin semblable à
celui ci alain mamba a voulu prouver aux
marins des telles que leur fameuse barre
redoutait depuis des siècles de tous les
pêcheurs bretons n'étaient qu'une vague
sans danger pour son canot pneumatique
vous souvenez aussi de la suite le canot
d'alain bombard et de ses compagnons
retourner et la malchance et dans le
bateau des sauveteurs venus à leur
secours faisant naufrage à son tour sur
la barre
sans cet accident du bateau de sauvetage
ils n'auraient peut-être pas eu de morts
ce jour-là à a- t-elle mais le mauvais
sort s'en est mêlée et il y en a eu 9 9
morts dont huit étaient loi s le mauvais
sort qui est coupable ou est-ce bon bar
pour les habitants des tél il n'ya
qu'une réponse c'est bon bar et le
catafalque géant est associé dans leur
mémoire aux deux syllabes de son nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois mois ont passé les tombes sont à
peine refermée et si les noms des morts
de la barre ne sont pas encore venus
s'ajouter à la longue liste des marins
d'etel péris en mer
l'histoire de cette journée dramatique
est gravé dans le coeur de tous les étés
la nôtre magnéto a enregistré pour vous
parfois à l'insu les intéressés le
réquisitoire de l'opinion publique
rappelons de sens parce que d'abord il
n'y avait pas lieu de tenter cette
expérience dans un endroit comme la
barre d'étel qui est toujours très durs
par mauvais temps
[Musique]
il semblerait que tous ceux qui ont pris
part à cette affaire dont bart se
seraient comportés comme des enfants ont
beaucoup dans la foule
d'après ce que j'ai pu me dire par la
suite parce que je n'y étais pas
personnellement beaucoup dans la foule
critiquer cette tentative mais il
n'avait pas assez de familiarité avec
l'administrateur qui étaient là pour
aller lui demander qui prenait la
responsabilité de ce qu'ils nous
préparent de ce qu'il présentait selon
vous bombarde peut revenir à l il sera
tjrs astuces alain bombard fait
désormais des détours pour ne pas
revenir à edel se sentent ils lui même
coupable c'est la question que nous
allons lui poser alain bombard nous ne
sommes pas des juges léger jantes à
s'occuper de leur côté de cette affaire
et nous n'avons pas la prétention de
nous mettre à leur place
d'ailleurs nous ne cherchons pas
déterminer les responsabilités au sens
juridique du terme non ce que nous
souhaitons vous c'est que vous nous nous
y vous nous disiez le plus sincèrement
possible
quels sont les sentiments quelles sont
les étapes les moments par lesquels
passent un homme à qui il est arrivé ce
que vous êtes arrivé alors pour vous
faciliter la tâche du groupe en somme
vous permettre de prendre des temps de
réflexion m avant de répondre à nos
questions nous avons inscrit ces
questions sur des petits cartons que je
vais vous passés les uns après les
autres
alors voici le premier vous sentez vous
responsable de ces neuf morts bien je ne
peux aller j'ai eu le sentiment que
j'étais la responsable était responsable
de ces neuf morts m'enfin je me suis
posé la question je ne crois pas qu'il
puisse y avoir un homme mêlé à une
affaire dramatique qui entraîne mort
d'homme qui ne se pose à un moment la
question est ce que c'est moi qui les ai
tués ou pas il est probable que je me la
poserai toute ma vie alors évidemment il
ya maintenant des événements qui sont
produits depuis qui prouve qu'il fallait
le faire depuis
il joue on ne le sait pas paris mais il
ya des accidents en mer tout le temps
dans la même région concarneau raz de
sein
devant et l est c est à l'heure actuelle
des hommes sont démunis de moyens de
sauvetage
est ce dû à cause de ça il n'ya pas 48
heures que ça s'est produit par la
chaîne boutique s'appelle la mme gaston
trois hommes sont morts parce qu'ils
n'ont pas pris le canot pneumatique
qu'il devait prendre il dit est resté à
terre ils n'ont pas après ils n'ont pas
repris la livraison du canoë qu'ils
avaient commandés il n'avait pas de
moyens de sauvetage trois hommes sont
morts
par conséquent de plus en plus si vous
voulez la justification à baisieux de
cet horrible accident se fait
quotidiennement
est ce vraiment la justification de
l'accident oui si oui en ce sens que
c'est la preuve qu'il faut étudier les
moyens de sauvetage et que comme je le
disais l'autre jour à maurice herzog kim
approuvait on ne peut étudier les moyens
de sauvetage quand risquant la vie des
hommes
ce qu'ils font le vis comme j'étais de
ceux qu'ils risquaient et je crois qu'il
faudra le refaire mais l'efficacité de
votre canoë déjà prouvé avant la
catastrophe des terres oui mail par
exemple l'efficacité des moyens de
surveillance officiel le canot de
sauvetage va tout le monde y croyait et
s'est laissé les moyens de surveillance
et de sécurité qui ont tué tout le monde
oui vous dites il faut prendre des
risques lorsqu'on fait une démonstration
une expérience scientifique mais à ce
moment là ne pensez vous pas que ces
risques ne doivent pas être pris
légèrement c'est vrai qu'on va prendre
des risques mais ils doivent être
calculées dans votre cas il était
calculé la préval non non vous ne peut
pas considérer comme mal calculé des
risques qu'ils prennent comme ces deux
des gens qui prennent des risques en
ayant comme sécurité pour les ramasser
si ce risque se révèle être réel s'il ya
un premier accident en prenant compte
pour sécurité les engins de sécurité qui
sont précisément prévu pour ces cas là
par exemple vous parlez du canot de
sauvetage d'etel et bien vous pouvez pas
m'accuser nous on peut accuser personne
d'avoir pris peu de précautions en ne
vérifiant pas le cas notre tâche détail
ne serait ce que parce que si on avait
demandé à vérifier son fonctionnement
nous l'aurait refusée je crois que a et
l émoi
cela résulte de l'est dans quelques nous
avons fait mais encore une fois la
montée je vous en prie vous voulez pas
placer la discussion sur sur le plan
juridique il sent que le canot de
sauvetage n'avaient pas ce jour-là son
équipage normal qu'au dernier moment le
patron du canot a dû faire appel à un
équipage recruter du moins en partie sur
place et qui peut-être n'avait pas
l'entraînement volume
or vous êtes arrivée et elle à 8h30 donc
il a fallu préparer le canot à toute
vitesse au dernier mini dock
quand il ya un accident quand tu es un
accident et ce jour là il faisait
mauvais temps dans la barre d'étel est
ce que vous croyez qu'on a le temps de
préparer le canot 48 heures à l'avancé
vous me rappelez vous nous appelez le
sapeur camembert qui voulait essayer les
pompes à incendie la veille de chaque
incendie à tous parfaits pas tout à fait
à montbard parce que lorsqu'il s'agit
d'un accident il faut y aller mais
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une expérience on va
la revoir
oui mais enfin il faut qu' il fallait
même qu'on utilise le canot de sauvetage
et c'est finalement pour tous les canaux
total de bretagne une bonne chose de
voir comment un canot de sauvetage peut
être peut être armé rapidement et à la
dernière minute car votre intention
n'était pas de faire une expérience sur
les canots de sauvetage mais sur votre
canon je sais je sais mais n'oubliez pas
que la sécurité nous a été donné comme
elles auraient été donnés un chalutier
qui s'apprêtait à passer là-bas ou qui
auraient eu un accident dans la barre on
nous a new day on nous a pas prévenus
nous que l'équipage n'était pas
constitué si on nous avait dit attention
il faut que vous attendiez l'équipage
normal nous l'aurions attendu qui parle
normal ils ont considéré comme
absolument normal est absolument dans
leurs attributions de faire appel à du
volontariat à l'instant vous avez risée
la vérité à quoi avez vous pensé lorsque
j'ai réalisé la vérité quelle vérité les
neuf morts moi je ne le savais pas les
neuf morts lorsque j'ai réalisé si vous
voulez que il y aurait des morts est
bien la première chose que j'ai pensé
quand j'étais saoul canaux c'est très
difficile à dire parce que je suis
persuadé que beaucoup de gens pensent
qu'on ne savait pas c'est un cerf enfin
de vous à moi c'est totalement sincère
quand j'étais sous le cas nous la
première chose que j'ai pensé c'est est
ce que je dois y rester aussi monsieur
poser la question comme ça c'était
facile je suis
il suffisait de couler j'ai beaucoup lu
facilement surtout dans ces cas là et
j'ai pensé à l'entraînement je n'en
avais pas le droit familial non et pour
ceux qui pour ce qui était en train de
mourir
enfin il y avait un enseignement à tirer
je ne crois pas qu'un mort de plus
auraient importé quoi que ce soit de
plus haut aux résultats de l'expérience
qu'au contraire il fallait au maximum et
essayer de s'en sortir mais la première
chose que j'ai pensé c'est d'abord
est-ce que je dois y rester ensuite j'ai
pas le droit des femmes et des gosses
une question voir pourquoi riez vous
toujours lorsque vous dites des choses
que vous jugez vous-même visiblement
triste je ris j'ai écouté je serais vous
je ne je ne m'en rends pas compte
vous savez que c'est une des choses
probablement qui me gêne beaucoup dans
la vie c'est d'avoir un physique je
reviens ligne est absolument certain que
si j'avais l'air d'un pisse froid on
prendrait beaucoup plus au sérieux et un
journaliste récemment faisant un article
d'ailleurs assez bienveillant a dit une
des grandes choses qui le gêne c'est de
ressembler à tartas est possible ici
mais on ne change pas son physique
ben je vous ai que j'ai dépensé
longtemps et puis ma femme aime ça alors
là tout de même voix au chapitre c'est
la priorité
et puis alors j'ai pensé j'y pense
depuis un certain temps et alors
maintenant si je la coupe est alors on
dirait que je me cache non c'est
certainement la dernière des choses à
faire
la séquence de film que vous allez voir
conforte de surprises ce film s'appelle
jeu dangereux et il a été réalisé par
pierre schlagg je vous laisse le soin de
deviner quelles sont les deux surprises
je vais simplement vous dire ce qui se
passe avant cette séquence l'héroïne une
jeune
voleuse de ménilmontant qui est chef
d'une bande a décidé d'enlever un petit
garçon de bonne famille afin de faire
payer une rançon par ses parents elle
fait donc enlevé le petit garçon mais
quand le petit garçon est enlevée c'est
très facile de kidnapper un ingénu mais
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de savoir
ce qu'on veut en faire alors vous allez
voir ce qui se passe
deux voyous ferait tout ce coffret tu
vas la boucle est oui
je vous ai dit que c'était juste pour
faire un coup pour étouffer un gros
client et le passé au peigne fin mais
c'était pas ça à seulement ça il s'agit
de julien vous savez aussi bien que moi
ce qui risque là qu'une seule chance de
s'en tirer c'est d'être défendus par
l'avocat champions ça coûte 500 billets
alors voilà les parents du petit sont
pleins aux as donnons bien son billet
pour récupérer leurs trésors les
formidables à dilma qui y voient une
seconde fleur
d'abord tu aurais pu nous demander notre
avis et d'une
secundo c'est pas toi qui donne les
ordres ici mais ne coûtait pas à l'égard
dacquois sur un graphe et pour le
restant de nos jours
julien était votre chef j'ai toujours
été régulier avec vous vous pouvez pas
laisser tomber maintenant le chef c'est
moi aller virer moi ce matin à lorient
vitesse ne t'a pas les toffes harpya
pour la succession du repas sera julia
et courageux t1 l'âge
laisse tomber qui ressemble il peut pas
causer mais il s'est expliqué il a
raison on commence par pierre ne
permettra pas dans cette séquence de jeu
dangereux je vous avais annoncé deux
choses nouvelles
je vais pas vous laisser attendre plus
longtemps et je vais vous les dire
la première c'est le nouveau visage de
pascale audret vous connaissez son
visage elle a débuté au théâtre dans
leur d'anne frank rôle d'une pureté
virginale jeune fille et vous l'avez vu
également dans l'eau vive dans un rôle
non moins pur et non moins virginale et
bien d'un jeu dangereux
elle a fait la performance de jouer tout
d'un coup un petit gangster en jute on
vous êtes metrics est assez nouveau
quand même la deuxième chose vous ne
pouviez absolument pas la divine et vous
avez remarqué le jeune homme avec qui
pascal sa frondaison assez violemment
il s'appelle sami frey et depuis qu'il a
tourné dans jeux dangereux il a eu le
rôle principal au théâtre dans l'année
du bac
eh bien ça me ferait le méchant garçon
de jeu dangereux est devenu le fiancé de
pascale audret on parle très souvent de
scènes d'amour commencé à l'écran qui se
termine à la ville mais on n'a encore
jamais vu de scènes de violence qui se
terminait en scène d'amour comment
est-ce que ça s'est passé pascal il ne
croyez pas ne croyez pas quand même que
j'aime être roué de coups nous je
connaissais pas ce n'est pas les
qualités de de samy que j'ai apprécié
quand même en premier moi je suis très
gêné de parler tout ça parce que parce
que de parler de sa mine de dire ce que
je pense de lui parce que d'abord il
oui il faut quand même que vous me
disiez parce que vous le connaissez
beaucoup mieux que moi je vais pas aller
beaucoup mieux alors qui est ça me
ferait du bien ça me ferait pour moi
c'était avant tout un très gentil garçon
très gai d'une qualité j'apprécie
beaucoup parce que moi j'aime aussi
beaucoup rire beaucoup m'amuser et plus
ça me gêne beaucoup de dire l'oci et
devant lui je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de
talent c'est vrai des prix et puis il a
des tas des tas de qualités que j'aime
beaucoup
j'ai vu beaucoup et vous ça me ferait
inquiets pascale audret la pure anne
frank ou la méchante petite héroïne des
jeux dangereux
si c'est comme ça d'ailleurs attention
non mais pascale audret pascal aubrée
c'est la pure anne-frank c'est la
méchante non la pipe gangsters de jeu
dangereux c'est celle au vif c'est cette
église a ni l'autre sénile elle l'autre
c'est pascal quoi fasquelle audrey c'est
autre chose c'est un dehors c'est une
comédienne elle a joué trois rôles mais
c'est je crois pas que et qu'est ce que
c'est dans la vie alors c'est une
personne que j'aime beaucoup qui me
plaît beaucoup
qu'est ce qui vous plaît beaucoup chez
elle tout vous savez c'est très délicat
de parler comme ça de l'état jon ce qui
vous plaît
alors vous allez vous marier cette année
cette année on espère bien au printemps
parce que moi je vais commencer à
tourner c'est un peu de temps parce que
vous êtes les biassais les plus séparé
de paris gwen un gain de 1,21 et les
jours de relâche ne sont pas lisses ou
pas les mêmes
alors vous êtes forcé de prendre rendez
vous par téléphone oui nous avons eu
beaucoup de chance de vous avoir tous
les deux aujourd'hui
eh bien écoutez il me reste à vous
souhaiter l'année prochaine de vous
revoir
et parce que pascal nous présentera un
nouveau visage celui d'une mère de
famille 1959 sera décidément l'année des
petites filles
après brigitte à 5 ans et anne frank qui
quittent l'enfance pour se marier
voici trois autres petites filles qui
prennent la relève de la célébrité
elles n'ont pas beaucoup à vous dire car
leur carrière
avant elle mais un jeune visage est plus
éloquent que des paroles
et voici la plus jeune gilliane hills
qui a 14 ans vadim l'arraché au lycée de
nice pour en faire une des vedettes des
liaisons dangereuses
elle a beaucoup voyagé elle a vécu dans
7 pays différents c'est une bonne
nageuse et elle n'est pas très timide
parce qu'on lui a dit beaucoup qu'elle
ressemblait à brigitte bardot vous avait
expédié votre photo à vadim n'est ce pas
c'est comme ça que vous l'avez rencontré
ce que vous aviez envoyez votre photo à
d'autres metteurs en scène oh non
seulement monsieur nadine seulement
monsieur m'a dit il pourquoi vient parce
que c'est un metteur en scène y avait
beaucoup qui a beaucoup de talent quels
sont les films de louis vous avez bien
j'en ai vu aucun écart parce qu'ils sont
interdits aux jeunes filles de 14 à 16
ans alors qu'ils avaient vu qu'il avait
du talent maman oui
et qu'est ce qu'elle vous en a dit aman
moment a dit qu' il était allé beaucoup
de talent et que c'est un metteur en
scène un formidable quitté très jeune
qu'il avait toute sa carrière devant lui
alors dites moi mademoiselle julian dean
ce à quoi rêve une jeune fille de 14 ans
quand elle va faire du cinéma bien je
trais marier avec beaucoup d'enfants oui
attelage au à 25 ans vous saviez la
deuxième petite fille s'appelle anne
braillard elle a 15 ans à mi chemin
entre minutes drouaire françoise sagan
c'est le bull à vernir de la maison
hachette elle et qu importe pour les
enfants dès ses débuts officiels dans la
littérature les appeler à 11 ans en
publiant fonds suisses dandinait montrer
nos dents
loiselle et puis en france à 13 ans un à
l'école sa prochaine oeuvre s'appelle je
crois pas de fleurs pour anne je ne suis
pas si j apprécie t il s'est fait trop
penser afin de reculer pour nous visons
les indices et vous n'écrivez pas encore
dans le style série noire il représente
pas encore vous écrivez depuis longtemps
depuis l'âge de 6 ans de ne pas envoyer
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée
d'écrire une fois et je m'ennuyais vous
comme je savais pas quoi faire je me
suis mise à écrire un co et puis je me
souviens ça passe bien le temps puis six
mois après je m'ennuyais d'une voie là
j'écris puis en quatre ans je crois que
j'ai christ est quoi je me presse pas
beaucoup
et alors après avoir publié pas de
fleurs pour aller où
un autre titre qu'est ce que vous avez
comme projet
quand je crois que je fais un livre de
contes de fées et puis vous retournez à
l'école
ah oui je suis ça vous habitez non je
crois que j'irai en france est ce que
vous êtes bonne en littérature en classe
une si bonne assez bonne et à quoi
rêvent les jeunes filles de 15 ans quand
elles sont romancière on a fait beaucoup
de livres si j'en suis capable
merci la troisième découverte est une
découverte et astral ce n'est déjà plus
une petite fille elle est même vénérable
parce qu'elle a eu 17 ans il ya quatre
jours elle a été choisie par barillet et
grédy qui lui ont donné un grand rôle de
petite peste dans la fleur bleue leur
prochaine pièce qu'est ce que vous jouez
dans la fleur bleue eh bien je joue je
suis donc la petite soeur de marie dance
de brigitte aubert et je leur fais des
dix ans nuit sans arrêt je suis assez
méchant dans lesquels quoi et on vous
prend pour nom
jusqu'au moment où on découvre puisque
maman découvre je suis marié
clandestinement et bien vous serez
parfaite pour jouer ce rôle parce que
vous n'avez pas hésité à vous marier
il y en a en marre justement et à quoi
rêvent les jeunes fils ou plutôt les
jeunes femmes et non 17 ans et qu'elle
débute au théâtre
eh bien je rêve d'abord de faire un
scream dans lequel j'incarne une
danseuse et ensuite je rêve
naturellement d'avoir des enfants
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans athènes l'acropole est une île dont
personne ne peut gravir sans émotion les
très hautes marches qui mènent au
parthénon ces colonnes dont on sait
qu'elles ne sont pas droites si elles
sont bombées un peu c'est que la vie la
vie antique dont le parthénon étaient
pleins à exercer sur elle une pression
qui ne finira jamais cette vie antique
dans quelques semaines le musée de
l'acropole en révélera un nouveau
fragments gars dans les salles
aujourd'hui secrète qui seront ouvertes
au public le 1er mars le musée de
l'acropole présentera une quarantaine de
chefs-d'oeuvre tous ont été les témoins
et les victimes d'un moment dramatique
de l'histoire d'athènes
c'est à une jeune écolière grecque rené
panahi tout cas mr 12 ans et demi que
nous avons demandé d'évoquer c'est très
lointain souvenir
[Musique]
vous apprenez votre leçon sur le
parthénon
oui vous savez qu'il ya eu 13 bat annaba
celui ci à la même place nuit que
sait-on du premier il ya des savants qui
doute de faire l'existence d'autres
techniques loi à quelle époque aurait-il
été construit dans le milieu du xvième
siècle avant jésus christ savez-vous
s'il en reste quelque chose
[Musique]
les savants d'île de france
je sais qu'ils sentent au musée leur
présente une lionne l'autre de lyon qui
terrasse un veau et du second parthénon
que reste-t-il les soubassements c'est
tout on ne voit pas dit s'il faut
s'approcher beaucoup pour les apercevoir
et du troisième parthénon
on était en train de le constituer
lorsque les perses envers athènes
ils ont tout cas chez les temples les
statuts lorsque les athées ça a été
terrible la sns atteignait on retrouvait
tous nos statues brisées et les intérêts
vous comprenez comme un internement
ils les ont enterrés là bas vous veulent
un grand trou dans la tête c'est là
qu'on les arrête ou levaient en petits
morceaux
après avoir été enterrés comme des morts
par les athéniens après avoir été
découverts cassé en mille morceaux en
1886 après avoir été restaurée ces corps
et ses merveilleuses jeune fille et
d'autres chefs-d'oeuvre aussi ont failli
périr une seconde fois
en effet lorsqu'on a reconstitué ses
statuts lorsqu'on a voulu assemblée à
nouveau ses membres que les envahisseurs
avait dispersé on leur a donné une
armature un squelette
or en 1886 le faire était à la mode la
tour eiffel était en train de naître et
tout naturellement on fit enfers ces
squelettes qui allait redonner la vie à
ces chefs-d'oeuvre
on ne savait pas alors que le faire en
rouillant à les ronger intérieurement
ces corps de marbre qu'il allait les
ronger jusqu'à les faire éclater pour
sauver ses statuts d'une seconde mort
donc il a fallu les casser à nouveau
il a fallu les opérer il a fait
extraire ces squelettes de fer qui les
rongeait et les remplacer par un
squelette en bronze
ces opérations car il s'agit de
chirurgie vraiment ont duré près de
vingt ans c'est pour cette raison que
depuis près de 20 ans le musée de
l'acropole interdisait au public
la moitié de ces salles ce sont ces
salles qui vont réouvrir quelques-unes
de ses statuts n'ont même jamais été vu
comme ce cavalier enfin pour la tête
véritable est au bout celle ci est un
moulage
voici dans quel état il a fallu les
mettre à nouveau ses statuts voici la
clinique du musée monsieur dont tu as
conservateur adjoint va nous présenter
le dernier malade qu'est ce que c'est
cette année recul non c'est un géant
c'est un géant c'est un géant qui
provient du fronton de la juvento
machine de l'hécatombe dont dans quel
état se trouve t-il maintenant est ce
qu'on lui a fait déjà elle a été la
statue a été déjà décomposer le faire a
été enlevé et du bronze a été substitué
à sa place ce sont ces petites choses
qui dépassent la voilà les bouchons en
bronze
et puis un autre et vous voulez vous
montrez ballon comment va tenir le bras
weir trez hir c'est à dire qu'il y aura
trois très gros bouchons qui vont relier
le brun motors
c'est dur je voudrais pas vous faire
porter plus d'infos que cette main qui
est à côté du bras
elle porte encore un
où jouera vers vous et voilà voilà la
main c'est la madjer salamin de gervais
voyez ce torse
des eaux de bronze appelé goujon vont le
maintenir pour toujours à sa place du
plâtre jouera le rôle de la chair
voyons pour un autre géant comment les
choses se sont passées première étape
autour d'une colonne vertébrale
s'ordonne les parties principales
deuxième étape n'est ce pas un vrai
squelette non troisième étape la
résurrection est accompli
et voici les artisans de ses
résurrections
c'est une tête de lion que l'on perd
fort doucement à se mobiliser a dit
canet jeu
[Musique]
constatez par vous
m
[Musique]
oui
ouais comme art
souvenirs dont il est en train d'enlever
le plâtre et le faire de la main qui est
temps de travailler maintenant avancer
la gauche aux enfers constation faire
remercions ces hommes qui depuis des
années patiemment humblement travail a
sauvé ses merveilles que le musée de
l'acropole donnera à voir bientôt à tous
ceux qui viendront visiter l'un des plus
hauts lieux de l'antiquité
[Musique]
et
puis alors tout sera fait pour ce cher
sans regret
[Applaudissements]
mais on ne s'est guère que cet homme
exemplaire en réalité sa belle semaine
et que depuis toujours chez smith au
négoce terre de père en fils attaque à
main armée rôle de pont tout genre
vielle aure nommé maison de confiance et
d comme hiver aujourd'hui comme hier on
est fils d'aller billon au respect de la
tradition le brouillard des censures
londres dans
la nuit se glisse une ombre celle de ce
que fait le roi tueur est cuit m6
thématique le voici à l'heure du crime
ab qpad mon sort you le monde est prise
khlie et tout ça il traite toutes ces
ateliers sont en fait la centième de son
récital
oui mais le résultat les commencé depuis
environ vingt mille eux lâche avait une
chanson vous avez tous reconnu seul
godfrey et la santé indique montant
correspond coïncide avec la première de
cinq colonnes à la une
c'est pourquoi tout allait il m'entend
présentera une chanson inédite et qu'il
chantera tous spécialistes
pour les téléspectateurs de cinq
colonnes à la une il chantera une
chanson qui s'appelle les mirettes
[Musique]
ailleurs et sans histoires 10 km en 3h
qui sonne c'est le moment seuls quatre
fils honneur voici le client
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ils disent là-bas
et bien voici donc une chanson tout à
fait nouvelles de roger vernay et marc
héral qui a pour titre les mirettes
qu'est ce que tu as dans les mirettes
mais qu'est ce que tu as
[Musique]
un sacré petit val musée
e
et ses cheveux
[Musique]
dans le meurtre et mireille
vienne valser
des p'tits gars en rouge laqué
est-ce que
et
pp
on sait que et soutiendrai ceux du côté
de nogent dans un petit verre
parce qu'ils sont bons pour un an
- au fond de tenir l
m
j'ai fait plongeon
et me suis cogné la tête sur un tas de
chansonnettes et un air d'accordéon
je tends ferme dans mes bras
on aimait turone comme un petit chêne
pense arrieta du rire au fond des yeux
et sabri même quand il pleut quand je te
regarde je me dis chaque fois c'est là
que mon soleil à moi qu'est ce que tu as
dans le mur
mais qu'est ce que tu as
un sacré petit bal musette
m
et ces chaleurs dans le bleu de tenir l
nbc
des p'tits gars on refait la terre
[Musique]
et
harper
en cercle et se dresse le
du côté nageant dans ce petit bar team
everest chimère qui sentait bon mauvais
temps depuis que d'en tenir être j'ai
même loge ans
j'ai eu peur des chansonnettes les bonos
plein la tête sur un air d'accordéon
ce qu'il ya dans des mirettes qui ne
peut tourner la tête
c'est là
amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui est michel debré et bien c'est une
question effectivement beaucoup de
français ce post encore et je dirais
d'ailleurs surtout se pose
principalement depuis hier c'est à dire
depuis que monsieur michel debré a
accepté d'être le premier premier
ministre de la vème république
évidemment nous savons tous que michel
debré est le fils du professeur debré
qui est l'un de nos plus éminents
pédiatre mais ce que nous ne savions pas
ce que la plupart d'entre nous qui
ignorait c'est que son grand père
paternel était au siècle dernier
un peintre extrêmement classique et que
son frère olivier debré est lui par
contre l'un de nos peintres les plus
abstraits
voici une toile deux toiles même
d'olivier debré nous savions que michel
debré était parmi les ministres du
général de gaulle celui qui comme garde
des sceaux avait pris la part la plus
active à la réforme de la constitution
mais pour la plupart nous venons
seulement d'apprendre que s'il a déjà
écrit quatre livres d'études et même de
critiques politiques
il a également quatre fils dont l'aîné a
19 ans et les cas des deux jumeaux 14
voici à michel debré lorsqu'il avait lui
15 ans en vacances
et voici la maison de nazelle en indre
et loire dont il était jusqu'à hier
encore sénateur et où il passe à présent
ses vacances
nous allons le voir maintenant en 1945
lorsqu'il était commissaire de la
république d'angers
nous allons le voir quand et comment
vous avez connu michel debré 7 il ya je
crois
trente ans en 1929 à l'école libre des
sciences politiques
c'était à la fin d'une conférence sur le
nationalisme
nous avons commencé une discussion très
vive sur le sujet et nous la
continuerons encore alors justement
est-ce que sk l'école ce caractère
disons d'homme d'action politique mais
aussi de polémiste et même de
pamphlétaire qu'on nous dit que nous
savons être le sien apparaissait déjà
oui dans l'élan la discussion il n'était
pas commode je me souviens par exemple
lui avoir dit quelque chose qui lui
déplaisent et sur les tourangeaux je me
suis fait vertement recevoir les
tourangeaux qui allait devenir ses
électeurs après est-ce que sa vocation
de réformateurs car michel debré était
d'abord le réformateur de l'école
nationale d'administration puis de la
justice et enfin et surtout de la
constitution est-ce que sa vocation de
réformateurs apparaissait déjà lorsqu'il
était à l'école oui parce que je vais
vous dire je crois que michel debré ne
peut pas se trouver dans un endroit sans
avoir envie de réformer ce qui
l'entourent
il était aux sciences politiques il a eu
envie de réformer l'école libre des
sciences politiques et il est entré au
conseil d'état il a eu envie de réformer
la préparation conseil d'état et c'est
comme ça que il est venu lui est venue
l'idée de la la future école nationale
d'administration
je me souviens encore ça devait être
quand il avait 24 ans nous avons passé
une soirée ensemble à mettre sur pied le
futur statut de l'école
la future école car à son point de vue
ce le recrutement était beaucoup trop
restreint et voulait
les tendres et surtout le démocratiser
et c7 cette école qu'il a lui même créé
sa demande de rsa en 1945 et où on a mis
nombre d'autres formes et vous ne vous
êtes jamais pratiquement quitté vous
êtes toujours restés très amis mais je
crois que vous êtes particulièrement
retrouver pendant la guerre oui c'est
une caractéristique de michel debré
d'être très fidèle dans ses amitiés et
pendant la guerre je dois dire que cette
ce fut assez curieux il était venu
déjeuner un jour nous étions perdus de
vue depuis le début de la guerre c'était
en 1943 si je ne me trompe et nous nous
sommes à bord d un peu sur la pointe des
pieds car nous ne savions pas l'un et
l'autre que nous faisions et nous avons
découvert à la fin du repas sami pas mal
de temps pour que nous arrivions à nous
découvrir que nous travaillons chacun de
là dans le même secteur mais plutôt dans
le même but mais dans des endroits
différents
puisque j'étais puisque j'étais moi-même
chef d'un mouvement de résistance et que
lui était au comité général d'études et
vous avez par la suite je crois
travailler ensemble et nous avons
ensuite travaillé ensemble parce qu'il a
eu la gentillesse de s'agglomérer un
moment de résistance
et même lorsque
nous avons eu des des arrestations
douloureuses comme par exemple celle de
mes amis avec qui il a il a pris une
part très bon de prévost des rentes à
l'action menée
je me souviens même que on lui avait et
il avait il avait un surnom très curieux
il s'appelait pentecôte pourquoi band
côte parce que parce que si je ne me
trompe
nous avions pris les saints du
calendrier et à la suite alors lui était
tombé sûr il ya le plus de 5 milliards
la pentecôte
alors il a pris pendant côte alors
dernière question que je voudrais vous
poser maintenant est ce qu'à l'école et
après dans la résistance vous aviez déjà
deviné en lui l'homme de d'état et
l'homme de gouvernement qu'il allait
peut-être
j'aimerais vous dire que je les devine
et mais malheureusement non je ne vais
pas deviné je croyais que michel debré
serait un très grand comique des je
savais qui serait un très grand commis
de l'état
mais je ne pensais pas qu'il serait un
homme d'état mais en réalité il a
toujours été un homme d'état c'est à
dire que il a l'instinct
instinctivement l'état fait partie de
son de lui même il a forgé cette école
d'administration pour faire les
fonctionnaires pendant la guerre il a
pris une part très active à la
résistance que je le qualifierais
d'activ mais tout de même le fond de sa
résistance c'était la volonté de
maintenir la permanence de l'état
c'est-à-dire de l'état de vichy à l'état
de la de gaulle
mais que ce soit le même état qui
continue c'était ça eh bien je crois que
il s'est rendu compte que en restant
dans l'administration il n'arriverait
pas à réformer comme il le voulait et
c'est probablement la cause de son
passage dans la politique il est entré
dans la politique pour rire
or mais l'état de l'extérieur alors que
dans l'indien d'administration et
n'aurait pas pu je crois que ça donc le
faire tout à l'heure que c'est monsieur
le comte boinet compagnons de la
libération et qui fut dans la résistance
et vous l'a dit d'ailleurs le chef de
michel debré que nous étions allés
interviewer pour savoir pour tenter de
savoir qui est michel debré et
maintenant je voudrais remercier le
président paul reynaud qui a bien voulu
venir en direct dans nos studios à cette
première émission de cinq colonnes à la
une car il ya une coïncidence historique
c'est que au seuil de cette 5e à d'olic
c'est que le général de gaulle président
de la vème république a été pour la
première fois ministre dans un ministère
paul raines ou dans les circonstances
d'ailleurs tragique dont vous souvenez
et que monsieur michel debré premier
premier ministre de cette 5ème
république a lui aussi fait ses débuts
dans la politique dans un cabinet paul
reynaud il était attaché de cabinet en
1938 je compte sur présence alors je
voudrais vous demander dans quelle
circonstance d'abord vous aviez été
amené à faire appel à michel debré qui
avait à l'époque 26 ans il vient nous
sommes en avant des 1 138
c'est à dire cinq semaines après munich
et à dix mois de la guerre à ce moment
là la situation est la suivante la
france est en crise depuis sept ans et
un détail vous indiquera la profondeur
de la crise
un wagon sur trois ne voulait plus sur
les voies ferrées françaises lors de la
boule de france sortait tous les jours
or nous avions besoin de l'art de la
banque de france pour acheter les avions
aux états unis il fallait donc faire un
adresse mans mais est la politique fait
depuis cette année avait échoué il fait
donc faire une autre politique il
fallait presque prendre le contre-pied
de la politique qui avait échoué c'est
dans ces conditions que je me suis
entourée d'hommes jeunes énergiques et
qui n'étaient pas des esprits
conformiste
car encore une fois il fallait aller de
l'avant et faire du neuf et vous
connaissiez déjà michel de bruit à cette
époque et bien je connaissais son père
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et en mai
milan et c'est par lui que son fils est
entré dans mon cabinet en avant 1938 et
je dois dire que les bras du le conte
services ont par ailleurs avoir donné
des leçons le team elite écailles à
regret le comité de lâches
ce comité à découvrir de tels scandales
dans l'oeuvre gestion de la ville de
marseille que j'ai dû écarter en
visuellement à la municipalité de
marseille lam et à haut fonctionnaire
avec tous pouvoirs pour redresser la
situation
si vous deviez définir si possible en un
mot le caractère de michel debré
peut-être son état d'âme
caractéristiques
quel serait votre définition du bien
cette aune homme qui à la fois il a eu
la foi et il a la foi dans un drame du
général de gaulle il a flat fois dans
une politique qui est celle de la
grandeur français il ya des idées qui
vous rapproche et plus des idées qui
vous oppose bien entendu oui parlons
d'abord de celle qui nous oppose comme
ça sa fille nous finirons nu il ya une
idée qui nous oppose celle ci s'est il
pense lui que il suffit pour faire
l'europe d'obtenir des conventions les
agréments entre les gouvernements de
divers pays d'europe indique
personnellement je pense en présence des
efforts de gigantesques que feront les
géants russe et chinois car les grands
réservoirs de l'humanité sont en train
d'entrer dans le jeu la chine
aujourd'hui et lendemain eh bien je
pense que ce miroir brisé de l'europe et
est une chose très touchant pour
laquelle nous avons tous une passion
profonde nous aimons autant je pense aux
deux patries demain qui y est
qu'aujourd'hui si nous arrivons à faire
une europe qui comme on en est arrivé à
faire une france en réunissant des
provinces qui jusque là avait été un
style
je pense qu'en présence du monde de
demain il faudra voir l'art d'y
installer jusqu'à là il ce qui nous
rapproche c'est que comme lui j'ai lutté
contre la constitution de la quatrième
république
j'ai lutté au point que lorsque en 1953
le président la république de l'époque
monsieur vincent auriol m'a demandé pour
la troisième fois me disait-il de faire
un gouvernement
je lui répondis je veux bien faire un
gouvernement mais pour réussir pas pour
échouer pas pour faire un tour de piste
de six mois comme les tabacs rade
et puisque vous insistez j'irai demain
devant la chambre je suis lé lendemain
devant la chambre j'ai fait le bilan de
la situation qui est agréable déjà et je
leur ai dit je n'accepterai de former un
gouvernement si vous investissez peu à
la condition que vous m'accusiez la
durée mais comme vous le savez ceux qui
profitent des abus ne veulent jamais les
corriger c'est pour cela qu'il ya eu des
révolutions est-ce que vous vous
attendiez monsieur le président à ce que
michel debré fut le premier premier
ministre cette vème république est ce
que vous l'aviez moi vous poser une
question qui appelle une question
directe qui appelle une réponse très
franchement excuses est ce que vous
aviez souhaité eh bien oui je le
souhaitais en ce sens que cette
nomination de michel debré comme premier
lycée dans la logique du régime nouveau
dans lequel nous sommes entrés il est
manifeste que pour que ce régime puisse
fonctionner il faut 4 le chef de l'état
et le premier ministre y est une
communion d'idées total et qui est en
même temps une confiance absolue
or chacun sait que l'une des
caractéristiques de michel debré c'est
d'avoir comme disent les gaullistes
traverser le désert c'est à dire d'être
restés fidèles quand beaucoup de gens ne
croyaient plus le général de gaulle
reviendrai et il a une grande le général
de gaulle a en lui une confiance totale
ce que je comprends parce est ce que
vous y croyez il serait prologue ce
premier ministre je pensais que c'était
la logique
vous croyez à la logique mais il est
certain que dans le régime antérieur
l'idée elle n'aurait pas traversé la
cervelle un candidat président du
conseil de prendre michel debré
communiste lui d'ailleurs ne le désirait
pas c'est être y avait incompatibilité
metz est indécis de la révolution
politique à laquelle nos gens d'assister
que michel debré y soit 1er bis et c'est
encore une fois la part la logique du
système
j'ai le président je vous remercie
d'être venus ce soir à cinq colonnes à
la une
[Musique]
ces trois petits garçons qui courent au
bois de boulogne n'avait jamais été
filmées
ils portent cependant un nom illustre
n'est celui ci le plus âgé il s'appelle
tout simplement charles de gaulle ce
petit charles est le petit fils du grand
charles
il a dix ans ses frères s'appelle yves 7
ans et jean cinq ans et demi
une jeune journaliste michel servent que
son journal avait chargé de faire sur un
reportage à l'américaine c'est-à-dire
par surprise décidé de le faire à la
française c'est à dire en demandant
gentiment d'autorisation à l'heure où
air que voici madame henriette de gaulle
femme de philippe de gaulle officier de
marine et fils du général c'est ainsi
qu'entre noël et le jour de l'an petit
charles ives et jean ont débuté devant
nos caméras tous nés depuis que le
général de gaulle s'était retiré de la
vie politique
ils ne connaissent que l'oncle charles
elle ignore presque le président seule
différence s'ils ont fêté noël à l'hôtel
matignon lieu de colombey les deux
églises fils de marin et petit fils de
général petit charles n'a demandé au
père noël ni bateau ni soldats de plomb
il a voulu à boules d'un air téléguidé
s'il existe une psychanalyse du jouet
enfantin il deviendra bâtisseur
[Musique]
cette séquence nous nous excusons pour
tout monsieur bac
ceci parce que nous n'avons qu'une
confiance relativement notre
prononciation germanique monsieur bac
donc ici quitte son poste
à l'heure de la première cigarette a pas
de travail beaucoup de vent aujourd'hui
à wolfsburg 80 km à l'est d'hanovre au
bord de l'autoroute de berne
faute d'eau et charmante cité tout neuf
fautes wangen à plus de 80% chauffage
urbain mais nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure quand monsieur pack sera entré
chez lui héroïsme bears allait presque
de soi
nous pressons donc monsieur bac à sa
porte nous le quittons pour tueur turin
au coeur de l'usiné fiat maintenant à la
recherche notre seconde interlocuteur
qui s'appelle monsieur est surtout due
aux actes étaient sous l'eau
le game vous l'a découvert un travail à
l'atelier de garnissage sur la six ans
je passe tous ici présents
il est la même heure que précédemment la
meilleure celle de la sortie au moment
où nous quittons le bon temps vient
juste de revenir dans les rues de turin
où la longue barbe bien super souto
rentrer souci c'est lui
il habite cité fiat via qu'une action
avec une excuse que précédemment
concernant la présence la prononciation
italienne 7
nous voici maintenant à flins est tout à
fait à l'aise et ce tandis que tourner
la chaîne ininterrompue de la dauphine
vous rencontrer monsieur pierre brunet
lequel s'occupe visiblement de
carrosserie carrosserie qu'il ne suis
pas contrairement aux apparences mais
qu'ils vérifient
ses pieds de démarches déjà un peu car
lui aussi attend l'heure de la sortie et
douaniers il n'a pas une minute à perdre
une pointage à l'escalier
et de l'escalier à l'air pur aujourd'hui
humide et glacé direction les mureaux
cité de la vigne blanche où il a son
appartement ou plus exactement il
devrait avoir son appartement
si quelques obscures ont fuit depuis au
de vidange avait retardé son
emménagement prévu pour le mois dernier
et robbie si tout va bien au 17 janvier
c'est ce pourquoi la caméra suit
monsieur bruner dans ce charmant
pavillon de maison un fort avec poirier
cent fleurs pavillon où nous trouvons ce
soir monsieur grenet redon que dans son
logis provisoire et avec une partie
seulement du bras de sa femme et mon
fils
hier six ans patrick cinq ans françoise
trois ans et mon quatrième que les pas
moins duquel ma femme se tient
actuellement ce qui explique l'absence
ce soir de manoeuvre honneur à notre
entame
mais monsieur pet food on nous attend à
turin via ignacio monsieur pèse photos
ici en haut de votre écran et monsieur
parc est arrivé par la même occasion
monsieur partie se trouve actuellement
rue joubert à force bourgs de maisons
alfort à turin et affole donc nous
allons ce soir donc par les marchés
comme un sens statistique d'yves
laminoir mais avec trois familles et une
tasse de café
elle vous trouverez des statistiques que
dans tous les manuels
nous parlerons ce soir avec des hommes
est tout d'abord de l'autre côté des
alpes à turin
monsieur que cette épaisse utp qui doit
nous entendre et nous attendre du moins
je l'espère de super dessous tourmente
un des superbes photos à table madame
plus tôt et leurs deux enfants
première question monsieur p dessous
taux nous irons très vite le multiplex
est un miracle coûteux et ce serait peut
être brutal
dites-nous très rapidement quel est
votre emploi chez fiat
quels sont vos heures de travail vont
au repos votre salaire moyen augmente et
éventuellement des avantages sociaux
dont vous bénéficiez immédiatement
justement je travaille à l'appui un
talent sur la scène de la naissance on
travaille caractères à 4h pour ce faire
le samedi après midi et le dimanche
un tour de table où tout centrer mais
c'est ma drogue ont tous à peu près de
cent cinq mille francs que tous s'en
servir pour la part d'hommes sans 5 mg
oui
et qu'est-ce que vous avez pas tous
tendus après qu'est ce qu'il y avait je
ne réponds seulement 20 jours à la fin
des vacances
sachant travailler le samedi après midi
et le dimanche
on le sent des après midi et le dimanche
je peux faire travailler sa mansarde
image avez-vous des allocations
familiales et de combien de lits en 11
minutes pour noah 4000 unir pour la
femme tient bon je me mis à dos et nous
allons revenir immédiatement à maisons
alfort où je vais poser les mêmes
questions à monsieur jean monnet qui est
bien revenir dans notre édition mais
c'est pas moi je suis contre la sur
chaîne à la fin de la tôlerie
j'aime bien et mardi ont un peu pas
60000 francs par mois en moyenne
cent quarante huit heures de travail qui
se décompose en 5 jours je suis donc
clip le samedi le dimanche donc nous
travaillons quatre heures de plus que
monsieur p dessus donc c'est bien vous
verrez une manie de peter c'est ça la
notation
pour les allocations familiales jusqu'à
maintenant je touchais mater en 1910
avec le quatrième que ma femme et moi
venons d'avoir cela se situera aux
environs de 30 mille francs chez lancel
d'environ 80 je me sentais bien dès
maintenant nous allons essayer d'entrer
en relation avec le super qui nous
attends je pense à wolfsburg
monsieur bac vous m'entendez vous avez
entendu les questions que se posent et
avoir deux camarades durant et paris
voyez bien attendez j'ai bien compris
quelles sont donc vos heures de travail
et votre salaire
moi je travaille 40 heures par semaine
je travaille pas tandis que l'image et
le gagnant par mois un peu près 500
athlètes en images ils vont bien de
vacances par an combien combien de
vacances favorable liévin lieu de
vacances et comme secondaire de
travailler ni le samedi ni les images
non non non non ramenée du marché paraît
pas avec vous des allocations familiales
votre famille pour vous ne partagez pas
de locataires famille a passé sa vie à
la part vous n'avez qu'un emploi ici
présents dans la natation aminian on à
part quelques allocations familiales
c'est une somme qui est versée en france
et en italie dans le voir en supplément
pour les enfants ou quelquefois la femme
qui me travaille donc vous n'avez pas
d'allocation familiale pour un autre
mais leur endroit là nous allons
immédiatement retenir en france donc
105000 lire à purin 60 mille francs + 39
ans d'allocations familiales à paris et
je crois 585 devise marque oxbow les
précise on vous devine que les
catégories auxquelles appartiennent ou
trois supprimer terroristes se sont
parlés même super soutoura de grade le
plus élevé monsieur back on track moyens
et monsieur robert ici présents dans le
grade affirme que le simple coïncidence
ailleurs cela dit nous n'allons pas vous
transformer d'office des changes et nous
allons immédiatement transformé ces
données ont été ordonnées nous sommes
ici monsieur bonnaire barre et pour la
télévision et d'autres rudin réunis ne
pouvez vous exprimer en moi et leurs
salaires
combien
éditions 39 à ma poste de télévision
nous coûterait à peu près deux mois de
salaire quant à l'automobile que je n'ai
pas mais prenons pour exemple une quatre
chevaux d'affaires qui écoutent
actuellement 380 mille francs avec la
ristourne dont bénéficient tous les
ouvriers de mon entreprise ça me
coûterait à peu près six sept mois d'un
message est pas de salaire j'aurais aimé
que madame veuve première de la sorte me
dire mais vous savez peut-être la
réponse à ma question de combien de
votre budget y consacrer environ à la
nouvelle hausse au moins les trois
quarts ou malestroit les voyages et
parlez nous maintenant ce que vous
voulez dire de votre loge nantes n'ont
passé mais une somme qui n'est pas vous
voir en larmes et scénic
ma soeur marianne pièce mon futur
logement comporte en attaque et séduit
si le cinq de base qu'est les loyers
mensuels charges elles sont pas bons
environ 15000 francs - les allocations
logement qui sévit à 5450 apple soit le
week-end environ un vingtième de
lausanne nous avons parlé viser les
balcons ferons pas ne pas parler de ceux
d'un confort en cas de maladie que se
passe-t-il pour vous votre famille ou
vos enfants comme maladie je paye mon
médecin je suis en danse et n'a pas non
médecin que je choisis de ma mère la
moitié environ qui n'est remboursée par
la sécurité sociale
quant aux médicaments que mon médecin
m'a prescrit s'établit à 81%
est-ce que je dois peut reprendre notre
sécurité sociale cereceda une super
souto à milan à turin ne savez peut-être
pas me battre
peut-être non plus monsieur p de souto
nous l'avons vu tout à l'heure à la
télévision nous allons tout de suite lui
demander pour lui combien représente
deux mois aux heures de travail le poste
de télévision qui se profile wii ainsi
que sa peinture si l'on possède une
[Musique]
mais justement pour ça elle ferait pas
mieux
ma femme savait télévision que nous
avons nous pousse à peu près un mois et
demi de travail de mon mari est mort
oui nous avons une voiture 1600 kg hot
wheels milan fiat et elle il faut
travailler cinq mois et demi à peu près
pour nous
et puis vous avez demandé quelque chose
d'autre je voudrais demander quel
pourcentage de votre budget familial
vous consacrer chaque mois à la
nourriture garder pour la nourriture on
n'est pas un simple après le choc un
push ou oui le sanguin touchant la
presse roumaine gagne et votre logement
que nous avons pas foule un peu
brièvement à l'heure à l'heure du goûter
des enfants se compose de chez de toi
piège cuisine et salle de bain
les solognots les loyers je peux dire à
moins d'un cinquième 5ème de cheveux
mais reagan et un cinquième du salaire
de votre marine et je dois dire que je
d'autres non c'est tout pour les en
remercier l'amour of north mara à
maisons alfort pour constater que le
budget afghan initialement ne sont pas
tellement différents plus de français un
peu moins dans la nourriture en italie
un peu plus ce prolongement et nous
allons voir tout de suite du côté de fox
bourgoin si les choses se passent comme
en france plutôt comme anita mathieu
parle
ouais vous avez entendu les questions
que les gens devraient savoir où elle
réalise certainement à bosse de
télévision on vient de voir sa vie avec
la représentait pour moi pelé travail
vous avez fait la prise demain pour une
fois c'est le médium combien de
télévisuelle et amine une voiture
combien de mois de salaire représente a
fait passer une voiture pour vous qui
est le président une femme puis mois six
mois
paulette la nourriture à votre budget
c'est à peu près le quart le quart des
actifs et et quant aux fanatiques de ce
type aux enfants malades et mourants ya
90% de 490 votre salaire est top cas la
pire à gratter tout est parti et bien
voilà que monsieur bac leur retourne
rapidement la dernière tasse de café a
été servi il serait peut-être de parler
du marché commun pourquoi nous sommes
réunis et voici notre guise
en finale avez vous peur vous monsieur
part du marché comme louis vichot
existants n'ont pas peur pas y couper la
route de rappel est bon pour vous moi
j'ai trouvé le marché commun pas fait de
bien que tout le monde nous allons poser
maintenant la même question à monsieur
fait de cette eau qui je pense nous
entendre ne voyons pas pour l'instant le
percement du tube est plutôt avez vous
peur du marché comme moi je crois que je
pense que le marché commun avec la
liberté de douane avortera de conditions
meilleures et plus de travail aux pays
qui leur en acheter
merci monsieur penneteau est maintenant
monsieur bonheur puisque nous sommes
d'avis son affaire en vendre deux villes
dans le monde la fin à des coupeurs vous
dis marché non je n'ai pas peur pour
salah enfin j'ai deux espoirs c'est
premièrement à la concurrence accrue
qu'il peut qu
produite au consommateur que
deuxièmement j'espère que les salaires
avec mon seul vaisseau totalité sur les
plis tavoris favoriser et j'espère que
les directions respectives de volks
wagen de fiat à turin et de harris
un message par an nous allons maintenant
quitté le petit pavillon de saison
accord nous n'avons rien voulu prouver
mais il nous apparaît plus que trois
européens moyens et irradie type au soir
de ventes
le traité de marché comme on est bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le travail du pape jean xxiii
avant cette audience de la matinée le
pape a accepté de tourner une scène pour
le film tu es pierre qui expliquera le
rôle de la papauté dans le monde moderne
ce reportage a été improvisée avant les
prises de vue écoutons jean xxiii dire
lui même sans expérience du cinéma le
plus c'est le martyre du majestic
monsieur justin va peut-être vous
expliquer comme il est le réalisateur du
jeu voilà par exemple le jour le moment
le plus caractéristique a fait pour moi
le soir romain m'a accompagné au balcon
de saint pierre devant la foule pour les
données la fénière des redditions tout
le monde se sépare en mouvement manger
n'est rien parce que ces réflecteurs
terrible et cela s'est trouvé face à moi
les avocats c'est la vie mais c'est dans
le film alors été la ville et votre
discours suivra le réalisateur du film
philippe agostini explique au saint-père
comment se dérouleront les prises de vue
le bureau de sa sainteté est plutôt
encombré ce matin par cette caméra en
batterie c'est que le film se tourne en
double version écran large et couleurs
le pape comme unique opère pichard
conseiller religieux du fil le texte
qu'il va lire sous l'oeil des caméras
c'est l'allocution qu'il a prononcée
devant les cardinaux du conclave
aussitôt après son élection il y
explique pourquoi il a choisi le nom de
jean
c'était notre semaine que j'étais au
vatican pour les prises de vues de ce
film les premiers qu'accepter le pape
depuis son élection c'est avant-hier que
j'en obtiens jean 9 celle obtenait que
le pape accepte de figurer dans une
émission de télévision sans doute le
cinéma et la télévision avait déjà voici
les gardes suisses
le sap r interviewé par jean 9 sel
à côté de lui son secrétaire particulier
monseigneur capovilla nous verrons tout
à l'heure monseigneur dellacqua qui
représente ici la secrétaire d'état
le paba s'adresser en français aux
spectateurs de la télévision
avec jr nous saisissons l'occasion qui
nous est si aimablement offerte par
dresser notre salut le plus cordial et
paternelle à la chaire france
elle demeure toujours si familière notre
esprit tel que nous avons pu la
contempler pendant de longues et si je
les années de notre vie
qu'il soit permis nos services au pape
est aujourd'hui de remercier tous ceux
d'entre vous qui accueillirent si bien
le nonce apostolique wierre étudiera
tous le souvenir inoubliable qui concert
de son séjour un gode patrie et puisque
nous sommes encore autant de souhaits de
nouvelles âmes nous vous adressons avec
l'affection de mon père nos voeux très
chaleureux voeux de bonheur pour vos
personne et vous voyez dans le respect
de lois de dieu voeux de prospérité pour
votre grand et laborieux pays part en
service actif et généreux du bien commun
et à ceux qui souffrent à ceux qui
pleurent à ceux qui peinent davantage et
qui peut-être en se lovant tourner un
gruyère confiance vers le vicaire de
jésus-christ nous voudrions apporter le
réconfort de notre spécial sollicitude
et l'assurance de notre prière
mais c'est vers dieu qu'il faut
maintenant nous tourner ensemble et nous
invitons tous à prier avec nous que par
l'intercession de la vierge immaculée en
cette année jubilaire du lourd le dieu
tout puissant et plein de miséricorde
réponse c'est grâce le plus abondante
sur votre chère patrie sur les grises
sur toute la communauté des peuples
santi apostoli parle ici d'un pronom
avis aux dominos ferait si vous êtes de
merris béate et mary s fair virginie de
a dit migueli sartre angeli béatrice
baptiste et santoro poster une perte de
paris est emmené au centre gériatrique
ingen absolution être émission omnisport
structures résidentielles corse
interprétation évité grâce à une
solution et finalement personne symbol
super 12 tribus travis omnipotent et
demie jaricot ce domino est de bénéfices
sur die omnipotent n 6 patrice est finie
et espirito santo deschamps de
supercross et marne et accepte
m
[Musique]
on
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]